first off a financial first for the
continent the Central African Republic
has adopted Bitcoin as legal tender
lawmakers unanimously approved a law
legalizing the cryptocurrency alongside
the CFA Franc but on the streets of
bangi there's Bitcoin bafflement as tws
zikoto Chaya reports
Sylvie is one of millions of central
Africans who hasn't got a clue what the
cryptocurrency burst is all about
Bitcoin needs fast internet but in the
Central African Republic only 11 percent
of the population have internet access
many do not even have the smartphones
required for the electronic transactions
when I'm selling and a customer gives me
a note I pay them back with coins
what is this cryptocurrency thing again
I learned that you need an internet
connection to work with cryptocurrency
but look at my phone it can't connect to
the internet how could I use
cryptocurrency
most parts of the country where River
controlled territory and very few have
any internet coverage at all even here
in the capital the bid rate is slow it
is hard to imagine how Bitcoin is going
to work under these conditions
but seven percent of the population do
have better internet access
Jean galvanese is one of the lawmakers
who voted for the Bill he says change is
coming the access to Internet I believe
it's a right but you're not a privilege
anymore in today's economy the
government has invested with the help of
the African Development Bank and many
other partners to bring fiber optics we
are in a process of implementing fiber
optic within the next 12 months fiber
optic will be operation in our country
so everyone who has a mean can get
access to the internet
but the opposition rejects the new law
and plans to challenge it in the
Constitutional Court
African Republic has a currency
it is one of six Central African
countries that share the CFA Franc
backed by France and picked to the euro
some members of parliament argue that
the move is simply intended to gut this
common currency others have speculated
that Bitcoin might be used to funnel
money from the Central African Republic
to Russia by passing International
sanctions
with friends apalco a financial analyst
rejects claims of Russian influence
why are people always saying Russia is
influencing decisions taken by the
Central African authorities no external
influence has nothing to do with Carr
adopting the cryptocurrency law
the advantage of the cryptocurrency here
is that it is a currency that is virtual
major Powers have long been using
cryptocurrency before it surfaced here
in Carr it will mean Financial
transactions can be secured by Central
African financial institutions
the government is presenting the
adoption of the Bitcoin in the Central
African Republic as a decisive step
opening up new opportunities
but bringing in Bitcoin has triggered
widespread doubts about the motifs
behind the move
I'm joined Now by Joy bira a business
correspondent from Nairobi Kenya hello
Joy now we had Sylvie at the start of
that report she hasn't got a clue what
cryptocurrency like Bitcoin is can you
briefly explain how it works
right Eddie thanks for having me well
um digital currency or in this case
cryptocurrency is a digital payment
system that unlike usual banks that have
to go through verification systems do
not do that so they do not rely on banks
to verify their transactions instead
they use encryptions to verify their
transactions one has a public and a
private key that they use digitally and
this means you need to have access to
Internet for you to be able to trade in
cryptocurrencies or in this case Bitcoin
so um you touched on so many different
aspects of it but it's not controlled by
a central bank so if you have money in
your pocket its value is guaranteed by
the central bank but who guarantees
Bitcoins
well the thing about cryptocurrencies
Bitcoin being one of them or the most uh
traded one of the cryptocurrencies is
that there's no regulation and it's only
between you as the buyer of the Bitcoin
or transactor of Bitcoin that has a
public and private key it makes it risky
because it's internet based and relies
heavily on blockchain technology so
should there be any kind of risk
involved there's a possibility that one
could lose all of the investment or all
of their money that's that sounds scary
I mean there's a lot of people talking
about why uh or wondering why the
Central African Republic will even adapt
cryptocurrency a Bitcoin as it's a legal
tender
um in figuring out why we've also seen
increasing Russian influence in the
Central African Republic which some
commentators have linked with this move
what might Bitcoin have to do with
Russia and sanctions
well there's this there's two ways to
look at it and one is with the ongoing
sanctions that are being slapped on
Russia as a result of its war in Ukraine
and that in itself
um has led to many African countries
that are heavily reliant on funding from
the West End in particular the United
States of America to now also start to
take action on uh some of Russians
relations with many African countries
and so this means that any transactions
are going to be affected and trade in
the US dollar is also going to be
affected so that could explain why
Russia is being linked to the Bitcoin
adoption in the Central African Republic
because Russia has tried as much as it
could to increase its influence in
Central African countries the Central
African Republic being one of the
countries where Russia has invested
quite a bit and the other way to look at
it is that Russia is also trying to get
at its quote-unquote enemies in the west
one of the countries being France and
them using the influence of Bitcoin
could explain why they are having much
to say in terms or at least there's a
suspicion that Russia is having
influence on the car's involvement in
adopting Bitcoin as Lego tender so now
briefly talking about a Central African
Republic It's a country that is rich in
resources diamonds gold and uranium but
also one of the poorest countries on the
planet who will benefit from this change
and how
foreign
so it's safe to say Eddie that the
Central African Republic being a country
with about 5 million people and a per
capita of about
525 dollars that really doesn't
guarantee the decision that has been
made by the country in itself to adopt
um this over the CFA Franc but then
again if you look at the number of users
of internet in the Central African
Republic it doesn't exceed 600 000 so
that could mean that these same 600 000
people are the people who drive the
economy for lack of a better way to put
it but where does that leave the rest of
the four million uh Central African
Republicans this means the inequality
gaps are quite wide and could even widen
more with the adoption of Bitcoin as as
we see it so many more questions to ask
but uh due to time we'll leave it here
Joy beera business correspondent in
Nairobi Kenya thank you